hello and welcome to this month's
episode of updating ancient archer the
uh game engine so i just closed the pull
request you're just in time welcome all
right so let's go over what has changed
since the last month and by the way hi
i'm matt if you like code stuff consider
subscribing and uh yeah let's just get
right into it i've been working on this
a ton as you can see this is the april
19th release and i don't know if the
binary is going to be available today
but i'll try to make that available as
soon as i can so people can try it out
if they want okay well let's look at
these lines of code change that's kind
of important right so looks like i
worked with about i guess that would be
about 000 lines of code including the
add-in remove together that's
interesting okay well that's uh a decent
amount i guess so here's basically
everything that got added in this latest
version of the game engine we'll show it
off shortly i'll try to leave timestamps
um yeah all this stuff i guess i just
read it out loud like one of those guys
that reads more and slides to you all
right we
fixed well this is going to get a little
nerdy we'll just we'll just say that
cash animated models uh yes this is
for part of the loader system and we
basically just don't want to reload the
same models twice so if something's
already been loaded it'll just reuse
what it already uploaded to the graphics
card if it's the same thing um that's a
pretty nice little improvement of course
i added a bunch of new lighting formulas
this actually this big focus was all on
lighting i spent most of the time
messing with lighting
and
uh yeah there's blindfold fong and
galrond and they're basically just auto
use and switch between them as needed
and i added some lighting tests we'll
show those here shortly um i prepped for
shadows um i didn't quite get shadows
done i was trying to i actually have a
demo of it working but there's a lot of
configuring to do with shadows and i
still gotta add them to all the lights
but uh it's on the way
i just need more time all right we
changed the way you access the props you
can now get uh well it's kind of it's a
it doesn't it's not even going to make
sense if you unless you see the code but
basically you can get access to the
actual objects and use their public
functions which is going to make it a
little easier once we go to uh entity
component system i believe so i just
need to be making a lot of those
refactoring changes as i go basically uh
for how the stuff is accessed
that way if you want to make a big
editor with this whole thing you can't
all right debug point light indicator
yeah i'm just adding some of those in
i'm still working on the other ones the
directional light one needs to be a
proper arrow and it didn't render right
and i kind of moved on so the other ones
are in progress but uh anyway gamma yeah
there's a gamma switch you can use on
just like your hardware
video card and i added the toggle for
that it's real ugly i don't know who
would ever use unless your game is way
too dark or something but it's uh might
as well have it there i need to add
shaders for this later when it becomes
important again but i got other stuff to
do before that i changed a lot of things
the skybox had some major changes
mostly in how it works it's now like
part of the camera basically or a
viewport so you just attach a skybox to
that basically um oh yeah i fixed all
the flying stuff and the tests that was
just movement basically movement
controls uh render pipeline rewritten
this was kind of a big deal i really
realized how i was doing all my
rendering and uh kind of set up a
pipeline um for opengl
uh this is what i what did i spell here
pipple line
oh well i didn't notice the
nail interface now get it okay yeah we
already talked about some of these
actually um remove a lot of old coach
sure okay a lot of bug fixes pretty big
focus on bug fixing too there was a
whole lot of issues with uh some memory
leaks and things not reusing memory when
they should in some of the ways things
shut down
that was the big stuff oh the stenciling
bug was fixed where it was uh not in
front of everything like it was supposed
to be so we got that sorted out with the
new render pipeline and uh some view
pause things that were causing some
light bugs and we fixed another light
bug that there was it was a normal
calculation that i was doing awkwardly
and it made everything darker than it
should be but yeah a lot of commits a
lot of working on this pretty much did
like four to six pomodoros most days of
working on this so i put in about four
to six hours a day on this and uh
yeah looking back at it to me honestly
this is just a retrospective a little
bit feels like i actually didn't do much
but i actually made like
some pretty big leaps in my
understanding of the render pipeline so
that's really good i mean it's not that
complicated but if you don't have it
like exactly
understood you're going to have weird
bugs that aren't going to make sense to
you until you do understand it so i did
get a lot of that sorted out
and that was really good
so it's going to make the shadows a lot
easier because i actually understand how
they work now and i was looking at some
of the more advanced stuff like pbr and
reflections and
stuff like that
and uh yeah it makes it sound a lot
easier so i don't uh foresee a whole lot
of issues getting the shadows working uh
all right let's look at some demos and
we're to the code and also to the test
explorer i know it's really tiny it's
kind of intended there's it's not like
you're gonna follow through and walk
through this code you know there's a
there's a ton of crap going on there's a
whole lot of files these all expand out
there's uh anyway so let's just go to
the tests so i've written up some tests
let me see if i can zoom these in nope
but uh generally what i do is just walk
through all these and add to them as
necessary so i'm just going to hit the
walkthrough button and they actually
didn't really go in the order that i
wanted them to but we should be able to
test out most of the features of the
engine by running these tests there's
only a few features that aren't properly
tested but i'll get to those at some
point all right here we go we got the
defaultednet window too all right and
then we hit okay and it loads up some
lighting tests it's loading right now
there it goes okay so just loaded up all
these models this animation put in all
these lights did a bunch of stuff
and uh here we are
so what we have here is a three light
system there's a flashlight attached to
my camera there's a little uh point
light down there and there's the
sunlight so if i turn the sunlight all
the way down i have it set to minimize
at .003 so so there's always a tiny bit
of sunlight but we can see the point
light more clearly and we can draw a
little debug thing uh moving around a
bit um this is just basically to make
sure that it lights up as intended and i
don't know how hard it is to see on the
old youtube so let's brighten it up a
bunch and turn its ambient down maybe
there we go now it's pretty clear where
the point light is or it should be so
yeah just getting to test all this out
in a nice scene when you're working with
lights you can really tell if it's
working or not i did have some weird
bugs with it cascading the wrong way and
stuff and i got all those sorted out so
that felt nice to uh get this light so
i'm gonna darken this light all the way
should be like completely dark except
for well let's turn off that debug cube
uh this guy he has an emission texture
on his hand and it just shows up because
it's a mission it's just using standard
glow uh let's turn up our flashlight
let's make it really bright so then we
with this kind of setup you can walk
around like a darker scene and you know
a little cave dark environment so the
spotlight seems to work pretty good as
well and this will be using basically
blend fong on all these guys that
actually have specular textures and the
floor doesn't but it still does the
shading pretty nicely just doesn't do
anything with the specular um which you
can kind of see if you adjust all right
so i'm going to turn that way down and
turn the sunlight back up whoa okay
there we go sunlight so that's basically
just the sunlight and just the
directional light and as you can see it
looks pretty good i fixed some weird
calculations that made it look a lot
better uh we can spin it around a little
bit you know mess with it as you can see
there's no shadows now i might show you
the shadows here at the end of this uh
they are somewhat done for directional
lights but what you might not realize
about this scene is this scene is
flipping huge uh like going from this
guy to this guy is like 200 units so
like most of the tutorials and stuff
they have shadows calculated for very
small little things uh not for kind of
giant 200 unit away things and 300 unit
tall things uh most of the tutorials
don't really talk about that so i need
to adjust a lot of stuff and figure out
play with a lot of numbers to get those
shadows right but anyway
lights are looking pretty fresh i think
anyway i'm pretty happy with them it
just it just works so much better and if
you don't want to mess with any of the
directional stuff you can just have full
ambient you know you can just be like i
just want the light of the room ambi
it's great it also it doesn't cast
shadows if that's the thing too but uh
there's no shadows here yet anyway i
guess i'm making that confusing all
right so there's that test i've been
working on mostly this test this is
where i've spent the majority of my time
um oh yeah i should show you the gamma
correction thing if you toggle that on
with opengl it looks like this uh pretty
awful but the thing is uh when it's
completely dark maybe you're playing a
game and it's like this you're like okay
game um what am i supposed to do i can't
even see you know how games do that too
sometimes very annoying you can at least
hit this and uh be able to see
so i figured i'd at least put it in
there that way if someone's making a
game with this engine they can throw in
their options or whatever they want to
do that's up to them all right well
that's pretty much the lighting tests
and how the lighting works currently um
yeah pretty pretty cool of course i
didn't really show it but you can add a
lot more spotlights and a lot more uh
point lights so you can add them all
over the scene
if you want i just had one all right
this is just a
model test i don't think there's
anything really yeah just a little
spinning cube so some of these become a
little redundant this is a reuse
resources so they're supposed to be two
guys and they use the same resources
which this will crash if it doesn't so
it seems to be working okay same with
the cubes let's uh go to the next one
all right this is just a base animated
guy which is kind of a redundant test
all right here's some skybox switching
stuff switching it on the main cam and
uh when you toggle full screen it goes
black for a second on obs but there goes
so yeah skybox system it's pretty
standard it's not hdr yet but uh maybe
on next update so stay tuned alright
some sound effects just some basic sound
effects i'm going to click these it's
going to be kind of loud so loud warning
but as you can see they all work you can
click them at will let me turn the sound
down a bunch and click on my bunch
basically you should be able to click
these at will and just not have anything
have a problem
because they're all loaded up and ready
because in general if you're making some
sort of simulation you want to do this i
also have support for background music
but i don't have a test for that and i
know it's a little glitchy because i got
to work out a few things with that but
it does work it's just not perfect the
sound effects are
the sound is something i need to revisit
for sure but it does work for now all
right and this is just kind of a mashup
scene we got a stenciled cube here we
got a stenciled animating model here uh
this is you know just a click effect
or something you know if you uh playing
a game and you want to highlight the
units you have a selected kind of deal
generally what the stenciling is for
it's customizable um i don't know if
there's anything else really to show the
scene just mashing up a few things and
making sure it all worked got our little
fly controls yeah all right let's go to
the next one and we're on stencil
outline okay yeah this was a big test i
made some uh some cubes i stenciled some
models and basically you're supposed to
be able to see the stenciling combine
with all the selected models and this
was just a test to help eliminate bugs
and if uh there's a model that's not
stenciled like this here gray cube
should be able to see stenciled stuff
through it like so that's kind of hard
to tell on the cube but yeah all the
stencils you can see are see through
that way you can see them in your scene
maybe they're a quest indicator or
whatever it might be for your game uh
central stenciling should be my hand wet
god words um i don't know if there's
anything else to show on the scene just
a little test and some window option
stuff yeah i sorted out a lot of the
window creation stuff and uh added some
min and max heights that can actually be
custom set um this is the men it allows
you to go and yeah everything should
work pretty well the default callback
should handle all the base stuff uh yeah
that's the test that's the demos this is
pretty much how this version looks um
and yeah let me know if you want the
binary i'm gonna try to make it
available somewhere this code is
uh private i would link it i can link
the old version but yeah i kind of have
this pay wall behind my patreon and
supporter thing at this point so if you
want to go the extra mile i will give
you access to all this uh but uh for
everyone i will at least make the binary
available as soon as i can i guess i
don't know where to upload it where
should i upload it how do you do that i
don't know i haven't really gotten into
the full release pipeline stuff but i'll
have to take time to figure that out too
unless someone wants to be a big help
oh special bonus you stuck around this
long i'm going to show you the shadows
and kind of how they work i'll try to be
quick about it but i think we'll just go
to
uh this directional shadows branch okay
now if we get in nice and tight here we
should be able to see a little shadow
right here on this cube now this cube
isn't perfectly on the floor and the
shadow isn't exactly perfect but it's
not too bad and it's a start and this of
course is uh all debug this isn't in any
version yet but this is kind of where
i'm at
let's see let's try changing the
direction yeah we can move the cube with
this one
so you can kind of see let me go up a
little bit change the sun direction and
depending on where the cube is i have
some area messed up it's like it doesn't
affect enough the scene and i need to
figure out how to fix all that ah so
that's kind of where i'm at with it um
yeah but i did kind of figure out that
if you turn up
these planes
a lot you can get some interesting
effects and i'm still trying to figure
out the magic how these work exactly but
it seems like in order to get any sort
of shadows on those big guys i need to
turn a lot of this stuff way up with
some what i'm still toying with here and
trying to find out so let's just try
this with these new numbers
and just see if we get any different
results because i i guess i'm going to
have to put this kind of control on to
the light and the shadows uh but i got
to figure out the best way to do that so
there's a lot of thought that needs to
go into this and a lot of testing
because uh and a lot of reading i have a
lot to learn about shadows so there's
just so many different angles to go down
when you're building a game engine that
it's a lot of solo work it's definitely
a lot of solo work now i can't even see
the shadow on this thing at all but what
about on these guys let's check them we
see shadows on them no not really let's
just move this light around see if we
get shadows at all so i might have
something configured really wrong there
i don't know but i'm ultimately just
scaling up these numbers i think i had
this at a thousand once and i thought i
saw some decent results so let's just
just have a look at what happens like
that now i don't know what you'd call
decent results exactly but basically i'm
trying to figure out a point where
actually these big figures actually cast
a shadow it's a lot of work i i
shouldn't try to go into detail i'm just
going to confuse people there are much
better sources to learn shadows than me
showing you my uh initial buggy
implementation there we go but this is
where we're at with it this is where i'm
at with it all right so now here you can
see some shadows this guy's got a little
shadow there this guy's got a little
shadow there this guy has no shadow i
don't know why all right so let's just
turn up these lights a little bit and
see what happens let's move the light
around and see what happens ah this
animating guy however is casting his
t-pose shadow so it's not getting uh the
animation so i gotta fix that as well i
think i know how to do that though but
as you can see with these large numbers
and these large figures we definitely
get some bigger shadows that we can work
with and you can see how they're
programmed there um but now you can't
see it on these little objects so
interesting so there's some things to
toy with there to get these shadows
right now ultimately i could just i
don't know i guess i'm gonna have to to
configure a few things but they do work
and they do work half decently for what
they are uh
to some extent so it's better than
nothing it's better than no shadows at
all in my opinion because shadows just
brings a lot of depth to an engine or
anything but uh it's definitely not
going to be passable because look at
that separation that's really awkward
that shouldn't be happening so we'll
just have to adjust a lot of things and
uh all right well that's that's pretty
much where that's at but that's going to
be the next phase so in a month from
today i will post another update on the
engine and hopefully another binary
release and and yeah we'll see just
gonna move it along as much as i can
keep releasing one a month so i hope you
guys are staying tuned and interested in
staying healthy most importantly and all
that
because uh yeah you guys have made this
channel what it is and i really
appreciate you and that's that's all i
want to say i guess really all right
well let me know if you have any
questions or comments down below and
until then until next time peace out
[Music]
you